which brings us to
the opening that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now for years republicans essentially
just rode off california as they had new
york and new england states not going to
worry about campaigning there can't win
there right for the presidential we were
told that the gop was facing extinction
even and that it could even get wiped
out in a state like texas
national progressives focusing on wendy
davis as somebody who could help turn
texas purple
you're a rock star no no there's just so
many great people who are going anywhere
the fact that texas is up for grabs says
it all 2020 elections are approaching
and with them the possibility think
about this
that deep red texas could turn blue for
the first time since jimmy carter in
1976.
nice try don
of course we never bought any of this we
certainly didn't buy into the defeatist
mindset on the gop part
after all we know that liberal policies
once they're really embraced and enacted
well they end up producing only
resentment then a lower standard of
living more crime and of course misery
for everybody except maybe a few
plutocrats
year when the angle reported from san
francisco
we sensed that people there had just
gotten fed up with the crime the filth
and yes the homelessness
i have a friend who was mugged on the
corner right here at 2pm on a tuesday
broad daylight
it feels lawless people don't feel safe
in this city it's a reality it's not a
media ploy violent crimes are up because
of chesabodine's policies it's a catch
and release
i've said he's got the swiftest
revolving door in the criminal justice
system yeah even tolerant san
franciscans couldn't take it any longer
d.a chester boudin is out and now the
city has a chance to start making better
choices
i mean what did they think though when
they elected the child of the weather
underground duo of bernadette doran and
bill ayers what were they thinking in
san francisco
and it's worth noting where the votes
for the recall of boudin came from
the only areas where bodine did well
were white rich liberal enclaves the
type of you know progressives who live
there who just look down on the average
working person and who basically they
believe that their suffering is
justified for the greater good but
working-class people areas with high
concentrations of hispanics and asians
they turned out in droves for the recall
of the d.a
turns out they won't be fooled again
they want and they deserve a better life
so no amount of bad mouthing america as
a rotten racist misogynist or colonial
power
is going to make the liberals horrible
policies go down any better for the
working class of this country
think about it this way immigrants came
here because they loved what america
offered
freedom a fair shot at a prosperous life
schools that teach the ability to
worship in peace safety
but with democrats all they get is
racial resentment victimology high taxes
high prices open borders and out of
control crime
but look i don't have any great illusion
that democrats will see san francisco as
a wake-up call i really don't
because i don't think they will they'll
keep putting stock and another waste of
time and money i'm talking about the
january 6 hearings to try to deliver
them from their electoral disaster
coming up they'll keep talking about
coronavirus variants or
keep pushing deviancy on our children
they'll keep throwing in with the
cannabis industry so the kids will grow
up to be numb and dumb
and i think they're just going to keep
on believing that abortion is a holy
sacrament protected at all costs
they'll keep our southern border wide
open absolutely and of course they're
going to keep rewarding china and
punishing u.s manufacturers
it's still
democrats are worried so worried that
george soros is back at it this time
buying up spanish language radio
stations in an attempt to shut down the
conservative wave among latinos
now why are billionaires or conservative
billionaires don't think strategically
like this is anyone's guess
but any event i think hispanic voters
are going to see right through this
six dollar gas is six dollar gas
so saying bad things about trump or the
gop in spanish that's not going to make
the pain at the pump feel any better
so this is the opening republicans have
been waiting for
it's time for a 50-state republican
strategy for victory and that means this
fall states like michigan where governor
gretchen whitless whitmer should face a
serious challenge from someone like the
up and coming tudor dixon
and even the deep blue washington state
where senator patty murray is feeling
the heat from tiffany smiley who we
profiled last night
and in 2024 we don't want to win by 10
electoral votes we want to win in a
reagan-era landslide that means an
urgent appeal to all americans who want
to save everything we love about our
country
a return to common sense
an informed patriotism a respect for our
institutions from law enforcement to the
supreme court
an embrace of american history as we
continue to learn from our past of
course
look we know what works trump's policies
worked
he had rising wages no inflation a tight
border no new wars no free pass for
china
a belief
in america first
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else